BETWEEN THE ARM AND BODY OF THE
GOALTENDER.
NICE PASS BACK TO EVANS FROM REM
PITLICK.
PITLICK, AS HE'S DIVING, SHOVELS
THAT POPPED UP.
IT FINDS ITS SPACE.
THE CANADIENS HAVE GOT LIFE.
>> HIS FAITH OF THE SEASON.
REMEMBER, HE WAS FAMOUSLY
KNOCKED OUT OF THE PLAYOFFS IN
THAT SECOND ROUND SERIES WITH
THE WINNIPEG JETS.
CROSS GOLFER BEHIND THE NET!
TREVOR ZEGRAS.
RIGHT OFF THE ENSUING FACE-OFF!
NOT READY FOR THAT.
>> WHAT A MOVE.
HOW CAN YOU BE?
NOBODY EXPECTS THAT TO HAPPEN.
WHAT IS SO IMPRESSIVE ABOUT
ZEGRAS IS HOW CASUALLY HE PICKS
THIS BOOK UP LIKE IT'S NOTHING
AND JUST TALKS IT IN TO THE TOP
CORNER.
WE KNEW IT WAS A MATTER OF TIME,
BUT MAN OH, MAN, HAS THIS KID
GOT SOME HANDS.
THAT IS SOMETHING.
LOOK AT THAT.
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS NOT ON HIS
OWN HOME ICE -- IT'S A SHAME
MONTREAL FANS ARE NOT IN THE
BUILDING TO WITNESS THAT.
>> SAVED HIS HIGHLIGHT REEL
GOALS FOR THE ROAD.
THE FLIP PASS TO SONNY MILANO.